but came to this video playing in DD
from France a very frequent opponent I
have 13 games played and 9 and a half
out of 13 lost three Kim doing something
else here the Tauri attack that's a very
direct way to play
hey I don't think I've seen this
particular move order I've seen d6 with
this idea but now I can keep the bishop
I mean not that it is a super fantastic
piece but normally black plays this h6
g5 business - to grab the bishop this
didn't happen here okay so he can play
this nevertheless okay yeah not this I
don't mind
I mean I'm Farhad and development anyway
and this is this wait wait wait wait
maybe the maybe the C pawn and that's an
idea
well the T I have you for coming this
cannot be bad really if I have this
Center the question is okay let's let's
do that's too long castles at least he
needs to be very cautious now if he
castles long castles short I'm sorry I
probably have some attacking options and
long castles yeah this is chess this
looks really dangerous how does the
defender k-3 even
really [ __ ] long castles isn't playable
at all yeah he can move the see porn but
I will take it I mean c5g take c5 I
cannot believe in okay now I have a five
at least a five and taking on d6 yeah
okay come on that's enough
if he takes 95 would be a total total
devastation so that he didn't do so I
know I can take and maybe can play queen
bee 7 this is maybe still playable 95
intending nights here the check is not
leading to much I believe he can just
play King ahead maybe this one Queen a
six last night see 6 check so a good
intermediate move Bishop e5 d5 just
establishes the spawn I thought
this is how Paul stupid can you be
I wanted to take here queen bee seven
and then take on the eight and of course
then the queen is simply simply covered
how could you how on earth can you come
up with this idea
Wow now I'm not even better
I'm not even better with this offside
rook fantastic unbelievable
now they are moving to us in this
position probably because of this
strange a3 rook should get it into play
really quickly
got 95 unbelievable
they also see five here which is okay
maybe I can take that
hmm if I get in Rock f3 I'm even better
I came to my dad
okay so c4 I need to open up things here
check it so it's an equal shank and game
but I can ask we can still continue to
play I only need to be cautious that I'm
not doing anything too ambitious it's
simply nothing going on of course I mean
that this game is still as still as the
running is is really really really bad
yeah I don't think there is anything
really going on yeah this I thought he
can't rhyme check sheet I'm warning the
Queen trade is probably not a rook check
is probably not a good idea
hmmm but okay he's threatening rook III
and Ruby - so if he just retreats I
don't really know what I'm playing maybe
King C dream it's not clear wrong I mean
it does not look good
what is he doing here black resign yeah
I mean I came it was a bit of a time
issue but I really don't why did he
spend like 35 seconds in this in the
same game we had yeah I mean but they I
mean I cannot believe it that maybe
there really wasn't anything computer
skipping as equal this is just just
unbelievable so here if I've is just not
good this is the problem I mean probably
rookie one or something Queen e2 maybe
here maybe here this is a matter of
precision computer gives a rupee one
hmm you know this is this is probably
better just covering before for the
moment and trying to to have this option
Luke 8 a 3 later it's difficult for
black to to play a movie it seems mm
yeah this is probably better and then I
don't hear where this is just idiotic I
mean okay I can be glad that I'm not
like losing outright but it still seems
to be a an okay position yeah I think it
was equal very check see for not a good
idea and now here black is check like a
headshot and of course this is just a
drone
for a very long time but this is not a
draw of course needs to do something
like this no he aim to answer this with
king D 6 king f4 whisking f6 and then we
have four have a draw I cannot go
kicking e4 which would be the opposition
but this easily holds for black yeah
this was lucky winning away okay thanks
for watching